so I'm gonna cover about 80% of our
touring lecture Dave speaks even faster
than I do so he can squeeze more
material in than I can but I'm gonna
cover about 80% the meet of the lecture
we're gonna start by a retrospective
that Dave and I put together of what's
happened in instruction sets over the
last 50 or 60 years and how we got to
the present state and maybe why we got
the touring Award for work we had
contributed along the way then I want to
talk about this transition we're in now
the architecture challenges that arise
because of the end of Dennard scaling
and the ending of Moore's Law and just
briefly I'm going to briefly touch on
the new security challenge that's arisen
in the last few years that really
reflects the fact that we haven't had
adequate attention to cyber security and
it's about to become a massive problem
and then we'll talk a little bit about
the future and what we think some of the
future architectural opportunities are
going forward given given this scenario
that we raise in part to so take us back
to the 1960s iBM has four different
computer lines targeted for different
markets commercial scientific real-time
laboratory instrumentation all every
single one is incompatible in every way
possible they actually make different
disk drives for different lines
different instruction sets different
compilers and this is the era where you
had to load the card deck which had the
compiler on in front of the Fortran
program so that you can run the Fortran
program everything's different it's a
mess it's a mess they've got a lot of
redundancy in terms of how they're
building it so they had a brilliant idea
one two is a to rule them all come
through that breakthrough idea and it
was IBM 360 now in order to get that to
occur across a wide span of different
price points and different targets you
needed an approach to employee
the architecture that could be quite
variable in terms of implementing the
same is a but at different price points
that key insight was the insight that
maurice wilkes the second winner of the
Turing award came up with and that was
that micro programming could provide
that capability Maurice was struck by
the fact that the hard thing was really
to design the control for these early
computers not the data paths the data
paths are relatively straightforward
it was really designing the control so
Maurice had this idea well this is a lot
like programming each micro instruction
will each bit in the micro instruction
will control some control lines and the
width of the micro instruction each
won't be a separate instruction voila
he invents micro programming as the
solution to this designing this control
so that that was the key idea at that
time memory is still core memory it's
very expensive right so you could build
these in ROM that was much cheaper than
core memory at the time so that
represented a price savings as well as a
way to do it so along comes the micro
programming idea a bunch of people at
IBM get together and say 360 let's build
a set of 360s and the first announcement
is four different machines spanning a
data path width from 8 bits all the way
up to 64 bits roughly a factor of 4 or 5
in terms of cost performance differs by
a factor of 4 it's a stunning stunning
announcement one of the people behind
that announcement was of course Fred
Brooks together with Bob Evans and gene
Amdahl the real creators behind the 360
and Fred Brooks of course won the Turing
award in fact he told me a fascinating
story on the day of the announcement for
the first time he meets Tom Watson the
founder and CEO of IBM and Watson
realizes that they're about to bet the
entire company on a couple of
thirty-year-olds and then he asked them
what they make and when they tell me
what they make he goes I have to give
you a raise because if we're betting the
company on you I should pay you more so
that was the that was the beginning of a
real
and this was clearly a breakthrough
because here you had instruction set
architecture separate from the details
of what the implementations look like so
things continue to proceed technology
improves we begin to move away from
discrete transistors to MSI and
eventually LSI semiconductor B Ram
begins to become available in the late
70s and this would allow storage to grow
and people started to think about more
complicated architectures in particular
there was this notion of a semantic gap
that the problem with writing software
was the gap between the software and
hardware was too big so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna yank the hardware up
closer and closer to the software voila
the VAX architecture was built out of
that concept of closing that gap
introduced in 1977 massive growth in the
amount of micro code made but you
couldn't possibly build this machine
without micro code because it had real
orthogonality address modes were
completely separately specified than the
opcode and you could mix any address
mode in any instruction so it was really
a rather different approach
unfortunately these kinds of machines
got fairly complicated they got
complicated enough that if you put the
micro code into hardwired it you would
find your bugs in the field so they
needed writable control store IBM
actually had already piloted writable
control store because on the 360 and the
370 series they introduced the concept
of downloading diagnostics into the
control store and actually the way they
ran Diagnostics was you this writable
control store they downloaded it and by
the way they also invented the floppy
disk that was the first use of the
floppy disk was to download the micro
code on the 370 so they invented a lot
of technology along the way but this was
a way for them to to get writable
control store and that became very
popular to do research on that that was
actually what Dave Patterson's PhD
thesis was on both of us actually spent
some time
building micro coated machines - really
because that was the way you built
machines then I I am the on the micro
vac sand and Dave on this project and
there was one fascinating machine that
was really enabled by micro code and
that was the Xerox Alto it uses a bit
slice TTL but it actually built some of
the graphics interface and the Ethernet
support into the micro code and so it
was a very efficient way to implement
that and of course Chuck Thacker who
subsequently won the Turing award as
well was with the key engineer behind
that together with Butler Lampson who
conceptualized a lot of the software
things so then the first microprocessors
begin to appear rapid progress in the
1970s in MOS technologies initially and
Moss then much later in the 80s CMOS and
people begin to build microprocessors
what are they going to do they're
they're chip designers so what do they
do they copy what the mini computers and
the mainframes did that was a logical
thing to do at that time you know we
don't know how to design computers we'll
copy what those guys are doing because
they must know what they're doing
so they did indeed they copied them we
actually had an era that I like to call
the microprocessor Wars of the 70s where
Intel would announce a processor then
zilog would announce a processor and
they'd have five new instructions in it
and they'd show you these wizzy and
struggling of course they wouldn't show
you any compiler ever generating those
instructions because the only way you
would ever use those instructions was if
you wrote assembly code but in those
days that's many people who were using
microprocessors were writing assembly
code they didn't have very much memory
they really had to write something it
was compact by the way this is this this
notion on small amounts of memory and
compaction is the reason that basic was
originally interpreted because then the
code size could be really small and
efficient couldn't afford to have
compilers in those days Intel then
Gordon Moore had a great observation he
said ok we built this first
microprocessor now we're going to build
another microprocessor the first one was
really just in response to
customer needs and was a quick project
then he realized these things could
actually take off and the next
architecture we build could be used for
a very long time in fact he initially
predicted as long as Intel was a company
it would be the architecture they would
build so he sent a group up to Oregon to
build a machine originally with a
different name than the AI pecks a px
432 it was renamed the 432 and that
began in the 1970s 1975 and they started
working it was a phenomenally advanced
machine
they used capability a bit addressing it
had it had instructions which had bit
lengths it had custom a custom OS
written in Ada so this was a bunch of
computer science PhDs unleashed on the
world to design something and they and
they designed something really ambitious
unfortunately it was incredibly late not
announced until 1981 roughly six years
after it started it turned out to take
multiple chips its performance was
really slow it was never a successful
project but meanwhile here's here's
Gordon Moore on the team down and
sitting down here in Sunnyvale saying
uh-oh we're late and we're very late we
need a solution and we need a solution
quickly what was born was the 8086
architecture and they built that when
they realized the other machine was
gonna be very late it was a 16-bit
version of the other architecture a real
stopgap processor 52 weeks is the total
everything from architecture to
completion 52 weeks they are did the
architecture in three weeks ten
10-person weeks and they had a very
clever thing they made it assembly
language compatible with the 8-bit 8080
now why we thought in those days that
assembly language compatibility meant
anything at all but it was assembly
language compatible mostly mostly not a
hundred percent but mostly you could
take the assembly language programs but
then something incredible
happened IBM decided to build the PC and
picked the 8088 which was a version of
the 8080 architecture with an 8-bit
external bus and they did it for two
reasons one Motorola who they even IBM
thought had a superior architecture
copied more or less from the pdp-11
architecture was late and Motorola
initially hesitated at building a
version with an 8-bit external bus and
IBM really thought that was key to get
the price point of the initial pcs down
it's hard to believe those initial pcs
cost like three thousand dollars I mean
they were expensive at that time from
not doing very much so that led to the
decision there was another key factor at
the time they estimated the total
lifetime sales for the PC would be 250
thousand so Motorola said well you know
that's not so many we're not missing a
big business opportunity they sold a
hundred million units so obviously it
was a giant sales opportunity it made
the 8086 an overnight success and the
other thing which a lot of us didn't
understand even later in the in the
early 80s was the PC created the
shrink-wrap software industry and the
shrink-wrap software industry reinforced
the importance of binary compatibility
because if you were a shrink-wrap
software guy you didn't want to have to
qualify your software on several
different architectures if you could
find one dominant architecture you could
qualify on boom you get the whole market
relatively easily so that became a
bigger driver and I think in the in the
early 80s a lot of us thought we're
moving to high level languages UNIX is
written and C you know forget about
binary compatibility wrong wrong binary
compatibility was actually cemented by
the success of the PC and then
subsequently ms-dos initially and
subsequently Windows meanwhile Johncock
another winner of the turing award is
back there at IBM thinking about how to
build faster machines
John was a true renaissance man who had
been brought up in compiler world before
we're having lots of several machines
stretch IBM's famous early pipelined
aggressive machine but he was thinking
about other things and whether or not we
could build faster machines and the
world was changing I loved a language we
were beginning to emerge what that meant
was the target now was no longer
assembly language code but what a
compiler would spit out and that really
changed the perspective so John took his
group at IBM they worked on a simple
pipeline processor the 801 built in ECL
at that time but they also built new
compiler technology for it
they actually ported that compiler to
the 370 and generated code using a small
subset of the 370 architecture because
the compiler was built for the 801 which
was a load store register register
machine the code actually ran faster
than the native compilers which were
designed for the 360 why because he was
using a subset of the architecture that
mapped to a very efficient
implementation and not using crazy
instructions it exists like the Move
character instruction so they have a
great move character instruction allows
you to move 255 bytes from any by the
lined address to any other byte Alon
dress and works even if the two
addresses overlap so it has to move the
bytes correctly even in that case right
guess what there's a lot of micro code
to make that instruction run or it runs
slow for all cases including moving word
aligned structures right so the they
didn't use any of those instructions
code ran faster so there's another
landmark paper that gets also published
in the 1980s which is a analysis of the
evacs 11 780 written by mr n Clark so
the VAX 11 780 we all called a1 mips
machine because everybody thought
including the people at digital that it
ran 1 million instructions per second
then Clark and emergo do this
measurement and find out that it runs
only 1/2 million instructions per second
the CP
the number of clock cycles per
instruction is twice as high as they
thought twice as high they're off by a
factor two they also discover that 20%
of the VAX is a generated 60% of the
microcode but only 0.2% of the
instruction leave it out leave it out
you know I still remember once somebody
asked about about the risk stuff they
said well how can you take out something
and actually make it faster I said it's
simple take a marathon runner and take
20 pounds of fat off him guess what he
runs that marathon faster right so
there's a that's the key inside here
Patterson actually did some interesting
work at Dec at the time trying to repair
microcode bugs in microprocessors
because digital was already having
problems with that with the complexity
of the architecture so yep no I don't
think so
I think there one or two built there
were never very many built one of the
reasons they won't weren't built and one
of the reasons why IBM hesitated on
exploiting the insights was there was
great fear that they were going to wipe
out the existing markets for the 360 and
this happens all the time in big
companies they worried that introducing
a new product is going to wipe out their
existing product right I mean this was
the case with the PC at Digital
Equipment I mean so lots of people worry
about that rather than well to to
observations one is you might actually
grow the market by offering it more
advanced cable and the other is if you
don't do it somebody else is going to do
it to you and you'll be sorry yeah so I
think that's it yeah so then you know
Dave and I started to have similar ideas
like you know why have if this micro
code storage is RAM why use it why
pre-decide what decoding of instructions
in there why not just use it for
instruction cache and let the programs
decide what should be in the instruction
so we had that idea we also said you
know we can make the is a simple enough
the instructions look sort of like micro
instructions and they can be directly
decoded by the hardware we don't need to
reinterpret the instruction set at
runtime so keep them simple they're not
as wide but they're basically simple
that enabled the machines to be
pipelined and occasionally you'd have
compiled code for a few instructions it
also allowed us to benefit from chip
integration so in the early 80s it
became possible to build a full 32-bit
processor on a single chip and that
motivated a lot of thinking in some
sense the fact that we were constrained
to be on a single chip said well we
can't do things the same way we have to
rethink how they're done there was
another important breakthrough compiler
technology got a lot better and really
key breakthrough here was Greg chayton's
observation that register allocation is
is the same as graph coloring and that
allowed you then to use a lot of
heuristics which had been developed
graph coloring is an np-complete problem
but there are a lot of heuristics you
comply to the problem and it really
clarified the problem in a really clear
way and there was a giant leap in terms
of the quality of register allocation
which made these load/store machines
even better so Berkeley started on a
machine risk won and risk - we start on
the MIPS machine there was a phenomenal
period in here in about 1983 where
Berkeley and Stanford both published
papers about chips that are faster than
the fastest things that Motorola and
Intel built with teams of hundreds of
engineers and we had six people working
on only three working on the hardware so
it was phenomenal
insight now of course there were a lot
of naysayers there were a lot of people
said this is never going to work when
you put in virtual memory you put in our
other favorite thing all your advantages
are gonna are gonna fall apart one of
the reasons that in retrospect that we
had a hard time convincing
people about the risk ideas was we
didn't have a good scientific
explanation of what was going on oh you
could wave hat simpler it's better and
around this time after reading the paper
on the backs and backs performance I
realized I finally realized what was
happening they and that out of that came
this what we now call the iron law of
processor performance that was the basis
for Dave and I writing our first book it
became the kind of the cornerstone
formula that we used and the observation
was these risk machines are executing 25
percent more instructions but they're
doing them six times faster and that
benefit is six times faster was a whole
lot more than the growth in instructions
and that's where the advantage came from
this is documented in a well-known grey
paper by Bandar car and Clark where they
take they take am its commercial mips
microprocessor and compared to a state
of the art backs machine and they show
that in fact there's actually
performance difference of about three
forget about the fact that one of those
machines cost roughly twenty times what
the other cost but there was a giant
difference so what happened then Intel
people are really smart so they got this
instruction level parallelism stuff and
the fact that pipelining was a big
advantage that the RISC designs were
getting and they started a whole new
project took a whole new team of people
and they did something very clever they
built an instruction cracker on the
front of an x86 that would take the x86
instructions and for the common subset
that actually people used it would
translate them into RISC instructions
which would then be pipelined in the
back end that was a really clever
Pentium Pro design it really made a big
difference in terms of their ability to
compete and this was also a time when
processors were growing to the extent
that most of the processor was not
actually controlling the core of the
processor became caches and other kinds
of buffers
so that really closed a lot of the
performance gap and Intel processors
continue to take off eventually
dominating both service as well as as
well as desktops then we moved into this
post PC era where the world moved to two
different kinds of device it moves to
things you carry in your pocket or that
sit on your wrist or maybe inside your
car and it moved to the cloud and away
from the desktop that changed the set of
trade-offs a lot the first thing that
happened was you didn't want to buy a
standalone processor you wanted to buy a
processor core hunk of IP that you could
then marry with an SOC and put it in a
system on chip design and slip it inside
your phone so that changed that changed
a lot the other thing that happened is
all of a sudden energy became a key
important property because you're
carrying around your computer all day
you want the battery and everybody
remembers first-generation iPhones I
couldn't go an entire day and have my
iPhone connected to the net and have it
leave the battery so all of a sudden
energy became important by the way
energy is also critical in the cloud the
second most expensive part of building
and operating a cloud is power and
cooling so it's key there as well and
that and die area became really
important right the price that you have
to sell a processor for and this device
is a lot lower and when I go to this
device it's even cheaper so efficiency
became really important not just in
terms of performance but in terms of
these other measures energy and energy
and cost so what happened there are
twenty million twenty billion RISC
processors built last year mostly arms
but lots of other processors as well and
that market has become significantly
larger and unlike the PC market it's not
declining it's still growing rapidly
so today 99% of the processors out there
are wrist processors it took a long time
to get to this point but some
times you have a long path to success
now there were a couple other ideas that
got thrown along the way one of them was
VL IW as an alternative josh fisher had
an interesting idea it's sort of like
the microcode idea you basically run
full micro instructions multiple
instructions got packed into one he had
this interesting idea there were a
couple companies that tried to build on
this but of course the most famous and
the key idea was to really let the
compiler do everything not just some
things but really everything to control
the parallelism that would occur in a
given instruction the most famous effort
building on this was the Intel Itanium
Intel realized that they had to go to a
64-bit architecture and so just as they
had done earlier when they were going to
move to a 16-bit architecture for him
8-bit they said well maybe it's time for
a new architecture that old a x86 has
gotten a little old a little long in the
tooth and it had lots of baggage because
every there was the 8086 the 186 the 286
the 386 the 486 each one added new
instructions so there's a lot of baggage
so they said let's start again do
something clean so they had an idea
called epoch explicitly parallel
instruction computer based on the
general v liw ideas not identical to
them but based on it and they developed
it jointly with with HP starting in 1994
and the edge' was to build an object
binary object code compatible VL aw and
it was supposed to be the successor to
the 32-bit x86 I a 64 was the name for
the architecture they had another big
advantage
AMD would not get a license to make it
so I be in so Intel will be the sole
source which would help them but the
first chip was late it was supposed to
they started in 94 is supposed to be
done 97 weren't done to 2001 an event
didn't actually deliver parts to 2002
many companies jumped on this bandwagon
after all until old in the market and
they've been very successful but there
were some problems compiler
worked pretty well when they had
well-structured floating-point programs
and didn't work very well for integer
from random integer C code and that
turned out to be a real problem they got
a code size explosion for those problems
they had problems with unpredictable
branches if you're in a floating-point
program branches are a lot more
predictable if you're an integer code
they're a lot less predictable
they had problem with variable memory
latency because they had to go to some
kind of cache structure and if you have
a V like W machine you're supposed to
keep all the instructions together and
if one cache misses and another doesn't
makes it hard to handle and the out of
order people finally figured out how to
make out of order machines work there
was a long understanding of how to build
them how to create them and make them
work remember that the first out of
order machines with imprecise interrupts
of 360 91 that machine IBM delivered
about six of them it was never fully
debugged so there was a lot of hesitancy
about reuse in these ideas but
eventually people people figured out how
to do it and they dealt with Cashel
agencies it's a great quote by Don Knuth
the Itanium approach was supposed to be
so terrific until it turned out that the
wished-for compilers were basically
impossible to write and so this was a
lesson about how far you could push a
particular approach and it was a mess so
it's now called the IEEE tannic rather
than the Itanium
this was about a two billion dollar
project that didn't work out so what's
happened there's been no general-purpose
Cisco is a in 30 years it's not viola W
at least not for general-purpose
computing we'll talk about special
purpose computing because that's a
different ballgame and they've been
successful in the DSP market but not in
the general-purpose market so the RISC
ideas eventually came back into vogue
and became the dominant way to build new
architectures it was a long road to get
there but in the end the core
efficiencies and the execution
advantages
one out so that's sort of a quick
history of what happened in instruction
set architecture over that period let's
now talk about where we find ourselves
today I think we find ourselves facing a
number of fundamental challenges first
of all the end of Dennard scaling so bob
Dennard the person who invented the one
transistor dram thank you Bob also made
an incredible prediction he predicted
that as silicon dimensions shrank the
power per square millimeter would stay
constant so think about that if the
power per square millimeter stays
constant and I have more transistors in
there I have more computing power for
the same number of watts in other words
the energy required to do a computation
is dropping and that was based on both
voltage scaling and things that would
happen with capacitance scaling but
voltage scaling was a big piece of that
that's ended and I'll show you a graph
on that the ending of Moore's law
you know Moore's law was never a law of
course it was a prediction it was a goal
it was a self-fulfilling goal because
once you set it out there everybody
worked really hard to make it happen and
it lasted for an incredibly long time
but as I'll show you Gordon's quote all
Exponential's come to an end
there are also architectural issues
which I'm going to point out with
basically the techniques we use to
exploit the incredible growth in
transistors that Moore's law gave us
pooped-out they basically they are
increasing in efficiency became a key
bottleneck and then finally this
movement away from PC server to IOT
mobile cloud changed the trade-offs that
architects had to think about so what's
happened well here's the early sis
period we had performance going up by
about 22% a year that's sort of the
beginning of the microprocessor industry
through about 1985 then this incredible
period driven by risk and instruction
level parallelism
processors are going up at more than 50
percent a year then the beginning of the
end of Dennard scaling Intel makes a
famous announcement they say there will
be no more emphasis on uniprocessors
we're going to multi-core which
basically said the problem of finding
performance is no longer ours it's now
the programmers problem you have to find
the performance exactly
so they Dennard scaling came along we
had a few great years of multi-core but
then multi-core ran into this little
thing that gene Amdahl wrote many years
ago and those law been lots of papers on
Amdahl's law is repealed you know what
theorems cannot be repealed they can be
circumvented but they are not repeal
Abul so and those law became a real
problem and as we move to large data
centers where that's where the
multi-core big multi processors are
turns out it's very hard in a large data
center on any application you're doing
Google search YouTube Facebook to get
out all the overlap all the
synchronization all the serialization
that has to occur to keep the system
rational not necessarily impossible but
hard and that so that's become a real
problem most amazing thing the last few
years processor performance going up by
3% a year after what happens is 50% of
your kind of number that we liked right
3% of years a lot smaller so you can
actually see this play out really D rams
you can really see it play out D rams
so just look at this curve here we're at
actually better than doubling every two
years which is what Gordon's original
prediction was doubling every two years
we're at 1.5 X it you're a little better
than that then a long period where what
1.4 to X until you and then all of
sudden we're down to 1.1 it's like you
and and we go through all these DD
series of DDR s and they say there is no
next generation DDR we're done we're
done I said what were you gonna do
rememory that's your problem ok but you
can also see this Moore's law slowed
down in processors as well it's not
quite as dramatic but it's pretty big
when
I'm you get by the time you get out here
we're off by 10x and if you look at
recent things you're off by as much as
15 X and you can really see it begin to
split off but it got quite serious sort
of right around 2000 and as Gordon Moore
said no exponential is forever but
forever it can be delayed
you just can't delay forever forever and
that's the problem this just shows you
what's happened in terms of power and
the effect of Dennard scaling so right
curve is is nanometer-sized scale of the
technology coming down the the blue
curve is is the power and just look at
what happened here it you can see it
begin to end right in here around 2005
around 2006 2000 thought but the last
few years it just climbs like a bandit
if you had told me 25 years ago that
you'll buy processors from Intel they
will slow the clock down they will turn
off cores to keep from burning up I
would have said crazy we're never gonna
have to do that but in fact that's
exactly what we have to do so there are
key limits here in terms of thermal
power dissipation so they become real
and this whole notion of dark silicon I
who would have ever thought dark silicon
I mean it's you know we need dark fiber
but that was because they put the fiber
and didn't light it up yet but who would
thought you turn silicon often have it
be dark it's not the only problem we
face we also face a big problem in the
security domain so security is probably
a pretty sad story in that there was a
lot of emphasis on it in the in the 60s
and 70s there were lots of early ideas
there with lots of great work done on
machines like multix which really
advanced security invented a lot of key
early ideas unfortunately it didn't get
used by software and because it had
overhead cost it didn't get used it all
got dropped over time so the level of
support we had for creating secure
domains actually went down over time we
also got very confused we thought
we're gonna verify all the software
we're gonna prove that it's alright and
that's gonna solve all our problems and
that turned out to be much harder than
we thought it was going to be so we
didn't make nearly the progress we
thought on that we actually had other
dives we're gonna structure systems and
they're gonna be these micro kernels and
we're only gonna have to get this little
tiny kernel secure and then the whole
system is gonna be secure and then what
happened was for performance reasons
everything started leaking into the
kernel and we went away from these
little tiny kernels to much bigger
kernels and then they had all the same
problems so massive problems and I think
you inevitably reach the point that
we're gonna have to find ways for
hardware designers for architects to
work with software designers to improve
security there's also lots of ugly
things that have piled up over the years
Intel management engine that runs
firmware that runs when the Machine
first very first boots up that firmware
could do whatever it wants and you have
no control over it and there's no way to
verify if you're a user that in fact
there are no bugs in that there have
been things like fogies fuzz testing
people run x86 op codes that aren't
well-defined and they discover all kinds
of funny things happen in the
architecture so there's a lot of a lot
of stuff there then Along Came Specter
you know Specter is a fundamental attack
on the definition of what computer
architecture is it's not just a hole in
the implementation it's a fundamental
requesting of what does it mean because
what we think about is architects is we
think I can do whatever I want in the
implementation as long as the user
observable result is the same as if I
ran one instruction completion then ran
the next instruction completion then ran
the next instruction to completion but
what Specter does is it uses speculation
to create a side door attack and it
attacks through another venue it doesn't
change the outcome of the program but it
changes the performance behavior of the
program in a way that's measurable by
programmers so it leaks
through that and it leaks it because of
speculation so this is a mess to clean
up it turns out some of it can be
cleaned with software but not all of it
and certainly not all of it at
reasonable performance amazing timing
attacks the the biggest one leaks 10
kilobits per second there's actually a
thing called net Spectre that leaks
without even putting any code on the
machine it leaks through the network
interface now it leaks pretty slowly but
it does leak data there's a recent one
that can actually penetrate the intel
x86 enclaves which are used to store
things like cryptographic keys that are
very secure and you can actually
penetrate those you can penetrate the
wall between two virtual machines for
example so lots of holes we're finding
Spectre bugs at the rate of about one a
month they come up with a new one and
obviously something better has to happen
here and there are lots more coming you
can turn off multi-threading that turns
out to be a pretty big performance hit
on the multi-core machines so there's a
lot of work to be done here we need to
rethink what we mean by computer
architecture and what we mean about a
secure system somebody pointed out to me
that there's actually a quote in our
book that says that says the right thing
about what you have to do across
protection domains but since we didn't
know about side-channel attacks it
didn't anticipate that attack and it's
easy to miss this little subtlety by the
way the first side-channel attacks came
around a long time ago in the 1970s
there was a side channel attack on deck
system 20 that was a side channel attack
to get passwords so there they're not
like they're new nobody ever put this
all together by the way this is we build
chips with this bug in for more than a
decade for more than a decade and nobody
realized it was there that's just a
reminder of how difficult it is so we've
kind of gotten to the end of great
performance breakthroughs we've got
some work to do on security how do we go
forward well I think it's time to
rethink some of our base level
assumptions if we've got slowing Moore's
law and we've got all these other
challenges we need to think about future
approaches so where are the
opportunities
first of all opportunities in the
software world the good news is hardware
has carried all this burden forward if
you're a software programmer you don't
worry that much about performance
because the next year the processors are
gonna be twice as fast so worried about
functionality add more capability
develop move up to a higher level
scripting language in order to get
improved software program so a software
program productivity to get more
throughput from your programmers do all
that well that's in fact what's happened
incredibly efficient for programmers I
mean you can see students now writing in
Python will write code that would have
taken in a month they can write code
that would have taken me a year to write
30 years ago that's great not very
efficient for hardware as we'll see
hardware centric approaches I think Dave
and I both believe that the only path
forward is to go to domain-specific
architectures that dramatically improve
the the environment and the application
for that particular environment and the
performance that's achievable as well as
the energy consumption just do a few
tasks but do them extremely well and
then of course combination putting
together languages which help specify
applications for these particular
architectures and combining with the
architectures so here's that this is a
diagram out of a a paper out of MIT by
Charles licensing and its colleagues
called there's plenty of room at the top
and what they do is they take a simple
kernel matrix multiply admittedly just a
little simple kernel and they write it
initially in Python then they write
rewrite and see it's 50 times faster
than the Python version then they
introduce parallel loops to be used on
an 18 core Intel processor and that
gives them a factor 7 then they lay it
out so it makes good use of the case
- structure the the of the multi-core
that gives them a factor of 20 and
finally they use the advanced vector
instructions in the architecture that
gives them about a factor of 9 that adds
up to a program that's 63,000 times
faster than the initial version now
before I started doing computer
architecture
I broke compilers compiler writers kill
for factors of 2 63,000 if you even get
10% of it you're a hero by any stretch
of the imagination so there's a lot to
be gained here of course it's not a
simple process but if you want to work
on an interesting problem in compilers
look at that gap look at how much
opportunity there is there
domain-specific architectures are
another approach route themselves in
hardware think about accelerators think
about applicate hardware that's designed
to do particular things it's not the
same as a we're not thinking about
something like an ASIC okay this has a
modem in it that modem is highly tuned
to do a particular function it's
extremely efficient you look at the
throughput of that modem try match it on
a general-purpose processor it has more
throughput for the function it does than
an 18 core processor which will cost you
more than the entire phone costs right
but it's not
programmable what we're thinking about
is a set of architectures that are
programmable but are tailored to
particular domains examples neural
network processors for machine learning
GPUs for graphics virtual reality
programmable network switches and
interfaces so really tailoring things to
do those kinds of things properly now
since Dave and I are deep believers in
quantitative explanation for any
advances you don't just get to see this
domain-specific as a magic bullet you
have to say why it might actually be
better so I think there are several
specific things first of all more
efficient use of parallelism single
instruction multiple data is absolutely
more efficient than multiple instruction
multiple data
sumen the application matches it the
application doesn't match it's a
disaster because the performance is
going to be horrible but if the
application matches it's much more
efficient bli w is more efficient than
speculative out of order if the
application matches it so again we're
not trying to build a general-purpose
machine that's going to run random C
code we're trying to build something to
accelerate some specific domain where
the applications are written in that
domain specific language tailored for
that particular architecture they make
more effective use of memory bandwidth
caches are great except when they don't
work and they don't work if you have low
spatial or temporal locality and so if
we can build user control memory systems
that work better assuming again that I
have a compiler that can generate that
user control movement of memory back and
forth then I can get much more
efficiency then I can also eliminate
unneeded accuracy I Triple E floating
point is terrific except when it's
really overkill and if I can do things
in eighth or 16-bit integers it's a lot
more efficient than doing them in full I
Triple E 64 32 or 64-bit but I'll need
the key is I need a domain specific
programming language to get this so what
we mean by a domain specific language we
mean a language where the key insights
you need where the parallelism is what
the data structures are like how they're
organized how they're accessible is
easily visible this is not about taking
random pieces of C or C++ or Fortran
code and extracting that structure out
we tried that for a long time doesn't
work so really it's about writing in a
domain-specific language that conveys
that information and maintains it for
the compiler to match it to the hardware
right so CUDA TP tensorflow
OpenGL P for all examples let and
interesting new compiler problems too
because
now you have to match this
domain-specific language to a
domain-specific piece of hardware the
challenge all the classical challenges
are there we want portability we want
flexibility we don't have to rewrite our
code every time but we might be
compiling to machines which are rather
different in structure so lots of good
research problems what area
well while Moore's law may be slowing
down the rate at which papers are being
published in machine learning is growing
as fast as Moore's Law so there is
something growing as fast as Moore's law
but what this translates to in 2018 so
far 50 machine learning papers published
per day per day right well quality
what's the quality of all academic
papers I'll ask you but we assume the
quality here is as good as the average
quality of other academic papers so but
this was really I mean basically alphago
was a turning point it was a
breakthrough it was a real breakthrough
in terms of understanding how machine
learning could work and extend itself
and so lots of great progress in the
field the good news is lots of
computation lots of computation and so
now you can think about how to build
here's something that really needs
massive amounts of computation but it's
a very well comparatively well
structured program problem so we do
things so Google's done the tensorflow
processor to try to go after these and
have built lots of these things this was
what was used for the alphago match
it's an inference based processor
focuses on the inference problem as
opposed to the learning part of machine
learning but it's really tailored to do
that problem and in particular this this
is amazing because it pulls out old
architecture ideas which came around the
1980s and then got put on the side in
particular systolic arrays an idea of
how to build an array that's uses only
nearest neighbor communication and the
thing to understand about modern
processors
is communication of data is much more
expensive than computation you do not
want to think about sending signals
across an entire chip it's relatively
slow and energy expensive so it uses a
highly dense matrix multiply unit that
structured as a systolic array it does
64,000 8-bit multiplies every clock
cycle so you get 92 million million
operations per second out of the machine
now they're 8-bit multiply ads but if
that matches what you need to do it has
tremendous throughput it also uses
memories which are specialized to the
kind of application that's doing rather
than general-purpose caches so what do
you get when you look at that well this
is taking performance per watt since
power is the key limiter and showing
what you get you get about a factor of
83 times the performance versus a CPU
implementation across a similar set of
machine learning benchmarks
you get a lot more even than a GPU now
partly this is because the GPU is using
floating-point and there's a big
improvement in efficiency from going to
floating-point to short integers but
still you get that improvement it's one
of the things that we talked about being
the key to that improvement so a few
concluding remarks so we believe there
are lots of good opportunities to move
forward to really focus on these
computationally intensive things if you
think about what machine learning is
done it's taken programming and moved it
from programming by writing code to
programming by assembling data and
training with that data and if you look
at I mean one of the most amazing
results is the Google language
translation program they went from 1/2 a
million lines of code to 5,000 lines of
code and it's a more accurate system for
doing translation now there's a lot of
training that went into that lots and
lots of mega amounts of data and Megg
amounts of compute time to do training
but you can really
break2 so this provides a really
interesting new opportunity to think
about how we build machines it's not
general-purpose kinds of things but I
don't really need word or PowerPoint or
Excel or any of these other things to
run faster what I need is applications
that are really smart to run faster to
do interesting things so this creates a
new Renaissance like opportunity because
now unlike what's happened in many years
in the computer industry now people who
write applications need to work with
people who write compiler technology and
languages that need to work with people
who design hardware
so we're Reaver Takei's ngering distri
as it was before the 1980s and it
provides an opportunity for a kind of
interdisciplinary work in the industry
that's really I find really exciting
it's sort of like this great quote I
mean everything old is new again it's
back to the future and I think this will
provide interesting opportunities for
new researchers as well as deliver
incredible advances for people who use
our technology so thank you and I'd be
happy to answer any questions anybody
might have the first of those being sons
companies
sure sure
no I mean I think we wouldn't have come
as far as we've come without tremendous
breakthroughs in computer aided design
and now the fact that you can design a
processor I mean if you compile to FPGA
you can write whatever you want and and
compile to an FPGA and get it but that
those advances now the problem is we had
a whole bunch of advances starting with
the early work on on wire wrap machines
and other things then moving through
printed circuit boards then moving to
VLSI it slowed down in the last few
years but this new era there will
probably be an explosion of chip designs
because rather than one design intel
designs three different versions the
architecture it dominates the vast
majority of the market there gonna be
lots of people walking around with
little tiny processors the one in this
is different than the one in here is
different than the one in there is
different than the one in your computer
so we need all of a sudden you're going
to have a blossoming of architectures
and because they'll have each one will
have a nice little niche market but
somewhat smaller than the big market
you'll have to figure out how to get
that in design time and design cost and
that's gonna require some rethinking
about how we do our computer aided
design tools and how we design machines
to try to design get a shorter design
cycle that's gonna be key so that's
there's ongoing work in that area that's
gonna have to be critical Carl so I
think in the long run maybe you're right
we're gonna have to go to main specific
architectures but this is gonna really
slow down progress but it's going to be
tactical very narrow application
specific work so there may be another
opportunity here in the way of
intelligent systems that we can come up
with a general-purpose architecture for
intelligent systems and maybe couple it
with nanotube stack nanotubes maybe we
could get another 10 years out of this
before were forced into the
domain-specific cave yeah I mean I think
you could
we get another five to ten years out of
silicon just by being a lot more careful
about designing it and thinking more
carefully about how the architecture
design and how to get efficient energy
in the long term that's not going to
work I mean I think that the key issue
is if we knew how to build intelligent
systems in a way I mean machine learning
is just a small slice on it right and
we're not it we're not it we're not at
general AI by a longshot
so we're in the early days and we've got
this one method that works pretty well
for doing with supervising reinforcement
learning it's not a more general scheme
it's four classifiers right and you know
as a dragon mum pointed out in the talk
he said you know AI used to be this much
of it was cognition and reasoning and
this much was classification now all of
a sudden this much is classification and
the other why because we know how to do
the classifier part that's really what
made it happen so uh you know if a faily
gave me this great example she said look
here's this great classifier to
recognize animal pictures does a great
job cat dogfish zebra tiger ask it why
this is a cat and that's a dog
nothing well some statistical
mathematics about it looks like other
cats right but nothing really ask a
five-year-old why is this a dog and why
is this a cat well this one has more
pointy ears it's a little more furry it
has whiskers that are bigger tail is
kind of different you know so we have a
long ways to go to get to that and if we
could figure out how to do it and what
the architecture should look like I
think you're right we could get a lot
more performance out of that you take a
question about your slide just before
this one then you had which was
basically in sort of traditional metrics
I'm surprised you didn't put him famous
one for that period in the eighties
logical inferences per second yeah yeah
well so there's a problem right now in
the whole machine learning domain which
is
we haven't yet come up with ways to run
develop and run fair benchmarks so there
is this ml perf effort that's out to do
this out to do what spec did for
conventional machines here's the
application here are the rules here's
how you run it here's how you measure it
and of course the machine learning we've
got another issue which is accuracy
becomes an issue how well do you and
there are they're a complicate off so we
haven't even thought about you know with
spec there was a right answer right you
you run the code this is the answer you
should get if you get any other answer
your your run isn't valid right so then
we can measure the performance of it
pretty accurately you know in image
recognition well suppose I had a suppose
I had one version of the code that
recognized the images correctly 95
percent of time and I have another
version that recognizes the 98 percent
time but this one runs 20 times faster I
mean how do i I don't even know how to
resolve that issue I mean so we're gonna
have to figure out ways for dealing with
it there are other domains where we've
done that transaction processing is one
so on transaction processing the
measurement that gets used is you have
to complete each transaction you have to
complete 90 percent of the transactions
within this period this latency and
complete the remaining ten percent
within this latency so they've there are
other domains where we've kind of
figured out how to have these more
complex measures of performance we'll
have to do the same thing here talk a
little bit about scaling complexity
until about 15 years ago 20 years ago
Intel had a policy that only three
people in the corporation were allowed
to know the complete architecture of the
process so complex and so yeah rule
anymore because nobody could understand
the complete
and then you wonder why you have bugs
[Laughter]
well security vulnerabilities are
complicated okay so the a good way to
answer this question is how did we ever
get the speculative out-of-order
machines to work given how complicated
they are the failure of the three 1691
right which was a relatively modest
machine for doing out of order compared
to the more recent machines how do we
get to work what happened was people
coded some important invariants I mean
they took ideas out of the out of the
software verification world and said if
we can prove some important properties
about this machine then we can guarantee
that'll work correctly and the important
property was don't commit any user state
until you're sure that the instruction
is going to complete buffer it all and
by doing that you could reason through
that the machine would work correctly
how did the how did the specter bug
occurred well it occurs because you
don't change any user visible state in
the normal sense you change the state of
a cache line and then you use a side
channel to observe that cache line
nobody ever thought of it nobody ever
thought of it I mean I worked out in
those machines we never thought of this
we just thought it'd be very careful not
to touch any user state until you know
all interrupts all bad things are taken
care of and you 100% can commit this
instruction and we thought that was
sufficient to close the door and that's
why everybody missed it everybody simply
didn't think so we could go to a lot of
history but meanwhile the history of
Sacramento we're kind of developing
libraries hardware libraries yeah
is try to use the library concept yeah
yeah yep build the pieces if I write but
then you start plugging things together
and they don't necessarily compose in
this lot and maintain the same logical
properties somebody is designed yeah
yeah well that's there's another problem
I mean the supply chain problem is
another difficult problem we're gonna
have to solve so here's the problem the
problem I posed to people somebody gives
you a chip how do you know that chip
hasn't been hacked some way in the
supply chain I guarantee you I can put a
bug into an Intel processor that you can
never find because it's gonna when you
multiply two numbers and add a third
number and all three of them are right
it opens up a trapdoor right this is I
could and you'll never find it the only
way you might find it is by examining
the chip against the mass but that's
such a hard laborious slow problem I
mean it'll drive up the chip cost so
there's a whole set of issues here that
we really haven't solved and part of our
problem for security is how do you
verify that in fact that system is
secure well if the if you can't even see
the code that's running when the machine
power is up I guarantee you there's no
way you can verify it and people don't
see that code so there are lots of
issues like that that need to be solved
some simplicity in the architecture will
help it will help but it's not a silver
bullet because if the bug is in the
underlying implementation you're gonna
have a hard time you're gonna have a
hard time finding it and security is a
hard thing to prove that it's correct
I mean how do we check instructions well
we run a bunch of programs and then you
know back when I when I was working when
we're starting MIPS I wrote a machine I
wrote a test generator that generated
random sequence of instructions ran them
on two different simulators one at the
hardware level and wanted a high level
and then compared the results and try to
look for bugs that way that's how we
look for bugs
we don't have a methodical testing
process and for security we certainly
don't have one because we don't even
have a really solid definition of what
it means for the system to be secure in
the face of things like side-channel
attacks so that's why we got to think up
a new definition of how to measure and
and assess security and it's gonna
require some fundamental research you
know one of the things we tried to do in
this talk was remind people that there
are a whole set of new interesting
problems and they're probably not the
same as the problems we've worked on for
a long time for the last 30 years or so
but they're really interesting and they
provide lots of opportunities for new
research to chips I'm not gonna be
certain that I can trust you're not I
think it's gonna be very it's gonna be
very hard to do that I mean it may be
that different methods you have we need
different methods it may be that you
should be carrying you know you carry
around a gadget that every time you log
your machine in you plug the gadget in
to prove it's really you right and then
it knows it's really you and it sends an
encrypted secure thing to another little
security chip that has nothing else in
it but this security that's small enough
that I might actually have a shot at
verifying that it's correct and unless
those two chips agree it won't log you
in as you so we may have to do things
like that rather than just rely on
extremely complicated general-purpose
processor that we'll never be able to
verify that it doesn't have security
flaws so that may be the direction we
have to go cyber security is gonna
become a lot more important so we're
gonna have to do something and you know
part of the problem was security was
resisted is is is our fault as users how
many of you have a different password
for every single account you have and
that password has at least 20 letters or
numbers in it and you don't use a
password generator which means you have
at least one Ruhlman loan machine which
when I break into that I can break into
all your machines right it's just too
much a pain in the neck how
do I forget a password I start using
different passwords and I forget them so
then I have to get the password back so
what do they do then they send me
through SMS a two-factor authentication
and we know this is broken so so it's a
it's a real mess and we have to overhaul
our whole security infrastructure
because it's gonna become a really big
issue you know I'm a child of a period
when the word hacker was a compliment to
somebody at Men Carl is a hacker he was
a really good programmer it meant
something good now it means bad you know
and how much they've changed I do some
written down in a notebook with an
encoding that I hope nobody ever guesses
[Laughter]
I use an algorithm to but if you know if
you if you get one password you might be
able to guess the next one by the
algorithm right and and of course you
know it with rainbow attacks and other
things it's it's a mess out there but
the whole level we've got to get a lot
more serious about it I mean I think the
the value of break and you know in an
environment like a university where
people thousands of people walk in every
year with their computers with who knows
what's on them and bring in viruses and
things like that it's a it's a major
problem that we're gonna have to get a
lot more serious about any other
questions yeah you would have heard
something about risk 5he this lecture is
longer than we originally so what you
would have heard is risk 5 as the kind
of as a kind of instruction set
architecture to try to do open
architecture so I think Dave would say
open architectures open instruction set
architectures provide a way to to
provide the architecture available to
lots of people
after all open software has been
revolutionary why not open architectures
as a way to to build on that in
and also I think risk five has another
key advantage namely you know twenty
plus years of experience allows you to
say okay well let's not repeat some of
the mistakes that risk made along the
way incorporating some features which
were perhaps appropriate for the time
but not long-lasting so it's a cleaner
simpler architecture
I think it's it'll be an interesting
experiment to see how well this works
but simply the fact that you don't have
to pay licensing fees or royalties on
the core architecture so you can go out
and implement it without that is a major
advantage they've also done the way in
which they do instruction set extensions
is also probably the best wave I've seen
one of the problems with architectures
is over time they tend to add baggage
and it never goes away
so risk five has a different approach it
has a set of variants and extensions
that can be added but they're not
required to be present now the open
question is whether that results in a
similar fracturing of the software
environment or not that you get when you
have let's say different variants on and
architecture right different versions of
arm we're on arm version eight right now
for example so an arm version aid is
compatible with arm version six but not
arm versions before that so you've got
this this problem we don't know yet
whether a risk five approach will solve
that problem completely but it's at
least worth the shot to try to
understand how it might solve it so I
think they're going to be in this
explosion of of potential
implementations of architectures
system-on-chip is really going to play
to having a single architecture which is
implementable to a wide variety of
different performance standards
available on those so that's I think
that is a positive real possibility and
it could really be a significant step
forward in terms of how we design
machines Carl we may not progress
I mean in many courts it's I don't think
it's hams doll I'm well and applause the
performance problem my minutes if you
have a sequential pardon and no big
organization has a sequential part
sequential part they can drive it down
they can drive it down they can drive it
down it's just very hard to make it to
make a consistent system and everything
go away yeah well we don't we don't we
don't yeah we don't we don't well I
think mostly because our brains are too
small to reason through systems that
it's true but it's chaotic and people
object to their programs being chaotic
but it's high performance it is high
performance it is high performance I
think if we could get you know the
problem I once had this debate with a
faculty member at Caltech about this
whole issue and what it came down to
no it wasn't differ it was Chuck sight
so we had this debate we had this
fascinating debate and what it came down
to the debate was whether programming
parallel machines was hard or easy and
what it came down to was how you
measured program in parallel machines so
the way I measured was programming them
and getting high efficiency the way he
measured it was writing a parallel
program and we didn't care that much
about the efficiency yeah it's true as
long as the overall performance is high
but it's hard to get overall performance
to be high and end up with crummy
efficiency without doing a lot of waste
and that waste inevitably is energy I
mean the reason these speculative
machines hit the wall was they were
doing code that was they were executing
pieces of program they were throwing
away the results right and they were
burning power to do that and there were
burning power to throw the results away
and get the Machine back to the other
state so so efficiency becomes the
key property in a domain where energy
efficiency is not increasing
dramatically from generation to
generation and that that's makes the
problem hard throw away 20% yeah yeah
and of course this is what happens I
mean look look look I mean look at a
Google server there's tons of you know
what they are observation is cheaper to
do the computation twice than it is
sometimes to communicate the result so
you do the computation twice
not every computation but some the
security issue
speculation problems we have with credit
architectures is you know basically it's
a different it's a different problem in
that the energy power problem is a
fundamental technology problem it's the
end of a process that we were very
beneficial yet and probably actually
overlooked a bit nobody understood how
important that observation was until it
really went away and then all of a
sudden we found ourselves in a difficult
thing security problem is just a
question of redefining what architecture
means and what it means to have a secure
boundary between two things whether
they're two pieces of code running in
two different virtual machines or
between two separate machines or even
within a protection domain where I say
okay you can't read kernel data for
example and of course there are
solutions to these problems but the
software solutions they don't get you a
whole lot of they get you
probabilistically closer to a secure
system but they don't guarantee it so
now if there's a determined hacker who's
really determined and is willing to
spend a lot of time sucking out your
data they can still suck out your data
just slower so maybe that makes you more
comfortable
you